imagine walking into like a business
meeting with one of these I just like
setting it down like I'm ready to work
[Music]
okay so it's Wednesday April 19th I'm in
New York City 8:00 a.m. I'm walking the
Starbucks about to get the new unicorn
Frappuccino
[Music]
oh when you say unicorn Frappuccino I
think about like bubblegum which I
really really hope it's not is it Lisa
Frank yeah like that's what I make
you're like right one of those folders
in like drink and drink forms rainbows
um Sparkle sprinkles guy would think
something bubble gum or something like
cotton candy sweet like overpoweringly
yummy uncomfortably sweet baby oh my god
are we gonna share a lady in the [ __ ]
stuff it's pretty I think it's a really
pretty drink it's like too pretty
stop the video I need to put this on my
Instagram story because it's cute it
looks a bit like like I took like trolls
and just like put them in a blender then
play with a dash of like robitussin or
anything but props to who like made it
cuz there's almost like a design yeah
alright can we drink this down yeah
Wow
I kinda like it what it's not that bad I
hate it either it's kind of like
flavored milk almost I feel like I say
strawberry
what about exactly it's kind of hard to
swallow someone left a bowl of Froot
Loops yes out for like five days like
I'm not mad at this I would actually I
would get it like you know what sir
it tastes like a melted like marshmallow
heat or something like that you know
yeah but it's like kind of delightful
yeah nice little surprise good job star
but yeah the rumor is that if you stir
it a changes flavor
whoa do you want to try it yeah maybe
this taste can be redeemed with a good
old magic trick this is gonna blow my
mom yo its haze different dant it's
actually I can already see all the
middle schoolers in my town going to
Starbucks and getting it I would order
this if I were like going to a music
festival I know they get close mmm
Coachella try it looks crazy
tastes pretty good as for me I think I'm
just gonna stick to my Java chip for
apps it like tastes as a unicorn
Frappuccino should it's a cute look like
what my nails yeah you know that you
can't plan an outfit around this ring
which is pretty antenna cute